you may have thought that because zack
snyder's justice league is almost here
there wouldn't be any more trailers
coming but you'd be wrong on the
afternoon of sunday march 14th
hbo max released a new trailer for the
film formerly known as the snyder cut
and there's a lot of new stuff to gawk
at in particular we see a lot more of
ray porter's dark side than we have
previously
including the powerful new god
expressing his hunger to rule over all
existence i have turned worlds to
dusk all of existence
shall be mine but along with big
explosive moments of heroes warring with
villains and armies clashing there are a
handful of small details you likely
missed upon first viewing
a number of shots in the trailer show us
classic dc comics characters we hadn't
seen before and just like one of the
most famous justice leaguers none of
them are from anywhere near our zip code
our hemisphere or any place in our
particular corner of the solar system
while some reports about snyder's
original plans for justice league
claimed darkseid wouldn't confront the
eponymous team of do girders himself
a couple of moments in the trailer have
us wondering whether or not the ruler of
apocalypse might not be taking a much
more direct hand in things than
previously believed here are the small
details you missed in the
likely final trailer for zack snyder's
justice league blink and you'll miss it
but one of the most interesting moments
in the latter section of the new trailer
comes at around the two minute and three
second mark
very briefly we get a shot of a woman
who may be diane lane's martha kent
kal-el's adoptive mother and her eyes
are glowing bright red
of course even if that is martha kent
being from krypton isn't contagious so
why would her eyes be glowing like that
the most likely answer well that may be
diane lane it isn't martha kent
it's jon jones better known as the
martian manhunter in january 2021 actor
harry lennox confirmed the long-held fan
theory that general swanwick the
character lenox plays in both 2013's man
of steel and 2016's batman vs superman
dawn of justice
is the martian manhunter in disguise at
the same time lennox said he would
finally be revealed as jon jones in zack
snyder's justice league the alien hero
has a long list of powers in the comics
including flight
super strength telepathy and relevantly
to this investigation
shape-shifting it isn't a huge stretch
to imagine jon jones taking on the form
of martha kent
either that or diane lane's dealing with
some brutal allergies
martian manhunter isn't the only alien
hero the new trailer gives us a first
look at
at around 57 seconds in shots that
appear to be from the battle between the
forces of earth and those of apocalypse
in the distant
past we get a glimpse of a member of the
green lantern corps who looks nothing at
all like ryan reynolds that doesn't mean
he's completely unfamiliar however
at least not to longtime fans of dc
judging by this lantern's appearance
there's a good chance this is jalen gur
a green lantern
who's introduced in a flashback in
1991's green lantern number 19.
gifted with a ring that has no
weaknesses jalen gur becomes
overcompetent and dies for his error
well zack snyder's justice league deals
significantly into this deep cannon
well we actually get to see gir's
downfall brought to life on screen
time will tell but this kind of addition
would be certain to delight hardcore
fans
at about 1 minute 37 into the trailer we
see something that's never before been
portrayed in live action the deadly
omega beams of darkseid their zigzagging
pattern is unmistakable
and darkseid's target may very well be
jason momoa's aquaman
whoever it is they seem to be swimming
and moments before this shot we get
snippets from the underwater battle
between
aquaman and darkseid's lieutenant
steppenwolf that may not be the last
that we see of omega beams either
a few seconds later into the trailer we
see red energy beams firing at the
batmobile and at around 207 we get more
red beams firing at batman himself it
isn't clear if these last two shots
emanate from darkseid they don't share
the trademark zigzag pattern from what
we can tell
and there are plenty of other possible
origins in a film like justice league
for crazy sci-fi lasers
regardless just the first shot of the
omega beams is intriguing
when kevin smith first started spilling
the beans on what he knew about zack
snyder's plans for justice league
the story was that while darkseid would
have shown up it wouldn't have been
until toward the end of the film
what we see in this latest trailer could
suggest zack snyder's justice league
will give us a dark side who's more
involved throughout
fans won't have to wait long to confirm
all this speculation zack snyder's
justice league will attempt to crash the
hbo max servers on march 18
2021 check out one of our newest videos
right here
plus even more looper videos about dc
heroes are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one